hi there everyone my name's Brady and I
make various YouTube channels such as
periodic videos and sixty symbols
numberphile but this is actually a new
channel that we're starting and it's a
channel that I think is probably the
most requested thing we've ever had and
that's to do something about computers
so what are you going to see on here
well I think you're going to see things
about software and hardware programming
the internet gaming the history of
computers all sorts of stuff I won't be
doing it all on my own I'll be having
some help from a guy called Sean Riley
who's behind the camera now you might
notice I've got apples there but Sean's
a PC man so don't worry we've got a bit
of balance on the project now the main
thing we'd like you to do is subscribe
to this channel pressing the subscribe
button wherever that is in the current
youtube layout the videos are starting
properly in May but if you can subscribe
now that'll be good because then people
will be watching when we start we've
also got the whole range of social media
happening so check us out on Twitter and
Facebook and everywhere that's a good
way to find out what's going on behind
the scenes before the videos even get
made follow them if you want to find out
a bit more about what's going on behind
the scenes and finally we would love you
to get involved and tell us what you
want us to make videos about we're only
just starting we're filming at the
moment and this is a chance for you to
tell us what you'd like to see in these
films so perhaps put some comments under
the videos and then Sean and I all have
an idea what you want to watch and what
you want to see on this new computer
adventure everything about computers is
on the table no matter how big or small
thanks so much for watching and
hopefully you've pressed subscribe and
you're on board for this new channel
which we're really looking forward to